[inaudible] TO ORDER.
AND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WE HAVE
AN FARM PORTANTINO.
HERE PORTANTINO HERE BATES HERE
BATES HERE BRADFORD YOUR
BRADFORD HERE HILL.
YOUR HILL HERE JONES WE CASKEY
WE CASKEY HERE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE SEVENTY
BILLS TO HEAR TODAY.
THREE ARE TO PASS THE REMAINING
BILLS.
ARE SUSPENSE ITEMS THERE'S BEEN
A NUMBER OF BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
RESCHEDULED FOR THE NEXT HEARING --
AND I LIKE TO REITERATE OUR
MESSAGE TO THE AUDIENCE AND
MEMBERS OF TODAY'S TESTIMONY
SHOULD BE LIMITED TO FISCAL
IMPACTS OF THE BILL.
PLEASE REFRAIN FROM LENGTHY
POLICY DISCUSSIONS YOU HAD THAT
OPPORTUNITY ALREADY.
SERGEANTS -- DO WE HAVE ANY
AUTHORS HERE [inaudible]
I'M SORRY [inaudible]
WHAT?
ALL RIGHT SO -- SOME BILLS HAVE
BEEN -- TWENTY EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
THE REPORT DIRECTLY TO THE FLOOR
SO IF YOU'RE HERE FOR SB ONE
SIXTY SEVEN DODD.
SB THROAT TWENTY TWO TWENTY HILL
SB TWENTY TWENTY FOUR GROVE SB
TWENTY TWENTY NINE AND THREE
FIFTY AND SIX SEVEN ONE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SB TWO EIGHTY FOUR BY MISTER
BALLEN SB SEVEN SEVEN NINE FROM
THE LABOR COMMITTEE.
HAVE ALL BEEN TWENTY EIGHT EIGHT
AT THE MISTER HILL FOR GIVING ME
GRIEF MAYBE OUT ON NEVER MIND.
BUT WE KNOW WILL CONTINUE.
ALL RIGHT THE THE TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHT TWO ALIVE AND THEN --
COUPLE WERE PULLED OVER MR
PELL'S FOR SIXTY AND MR STERN'S
FOR SEVENTY ONE HAVE BEEN
RESCHEDULED FOR THE NEXT HEARING.
OKAY -- WILL START WITH OUR TO
SPEND SOME MISTER ROTH IS WAY
PRESENTATION ON SB SIXTEEN FOR
ANYONE HERE WHO WANTS TO SPEAK
ON SB.
SIXTEEN ON COURTS AND JUDGESHIPS
SEEING NO FOR NO AGAINST
[inaudible]
FILE.
GOOD MORNING MR SHARE MORE
NUMBERS STILL THE ON AIR WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WE DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED
POSITION ON THIS BILL BUT WE
KNOW THAT THE BILL APPROPRIATE
THIRTY SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
A DIFFERENT TWENTY FIVE NEW
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE SHIPS AND
EXPENSES ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE
POSITIONS.
OF FURTHER -- WE KNOW THE BILL
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND.
A TO REVIVE ONE DEALER FOR EACH
OF THE NEW GADGETS JUDGESHIPS.
WITHOUT SEEING ANY COMMENTS SB
SIXTEEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SB
ONE THIRTY EIGHT ALSO BY MR ROCK
ON PEOPLE HEALTH.
ANYBODY HERE TO SPEAK ON SB. ONE
THIRTY EIGHT FOR AGAINST.
FINANCE THE FILE NO FILE.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS SB ONE
THIRTY EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE --
SB THREE SIXTY TWO BY ROTH
UNPAID WAGE BENEFITS ANYBODY
HERE TO SPEAK ON THREE SIXTY TWO
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP FOR
ANYBODY RASH WILL GO TO FINANCE
NO FILE.
NO FILE ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS STOP WITHOUT OBJECTION
THREE STE. SIXTY TWO WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE SB FOUR SIXTY ONE MY
MISTER ROTH AND CAL GRANTS.
GOING IN THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION
SING NO ONE HERE TO SPEAK FOR OR
AGAINST.
FOR SIXTY ONE NO FILE YOU KNOW
FILE.
SEEING NO CONCERNS SB FOUR SIXTY
ONE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE.
MOVED TO MISS CAVELL GYROS BILLS
SHE HAS WAY PRESENTATION ON ALL
OF THEM SB.
TWENTY SIX ON TAXES CHILD CARE
TAX CREDIT.
ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OR
IN OPPOSITION.
YOU WANT TO SPEAK IN FAVOR.
OKAY SEEING NOBODY ON SB.
TWENTY SIX FINANCE THE FILE NO
FILE SEE NO.
AND MY COLLEAGUES SB TWENTY SIX
WITHOUT OBJECTION GONNA SUSPENSE
SB TO NINETY EIGHT BY MISS
CARRIER ON POVERTY REDUCTION IS
OR SOMEONE WHO'S SPEAKING IN
FAVOR.
SOMEONE SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION.
SB TWO NINE EIGHT SEEING NO RUSH --
NO FINANCE NO FILE SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP ON TWO NINE EIGHT
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWO NINE
EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SB FOUR FOURTEEN BY MISS
CAVALIER SMALL SYSTEM WATER
AUTHORITY ACT TWENTY ONE HERE IN
FAVOR OF FOUR FOURTEEN ANYONE
OPPOSED FINANCE.
WE HAVE NO POSITION ON THIS BILL --
HOWEVER THE STATE WATER BOARD
ESTIMATES THIS BILL WILL RESULT
IN GENERAL FUND COSTS OF MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
OVER THE FIRST SIX YEARS OF
IMPLEMENTATION.
OF THE WATER BOARD NOTES THAT
THESE ESTIMATES DO NOT INCLUDE
COSTS FOR SYSTEM IMPROVEMENT
NEEDED TO BRING SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS INTO COMPLIANCE WITH
DRINKING WATER STANDARDS.
OF FINANCE CONCURS WITH THE BILL
WILL REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND RESOURCES BUT NO
SIGNIFICANT UNCERTAINTY ON THE
SCOPE OF RESOURCE STATES.
AND AT THE TIME OF THIS ANALYSIS
WE HAD NOT RECEIVED OFFICIAL
ESTIMATE FOR THE BILL'S IMPACT
ON THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
PRICING NO QUESTIONS ASKED
BEFORE FOURTEEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
TRANSACTION.
HE'S ON THE FIRST PAGE.
WITHIN THE AREA.
MS JACKSON I SEE THAT YOU'RE.
BILLS ARE SLATEDFOR SUSPENSE --
WAVING PRESENTATION ON SB ONE
SEVEN ONE BUT I UNDERSTAND YOU
WANT TO PRESENT ON THE OTHER.
THREE IF I MAY BRIEFLY.
THAT WOULD BE WONDERFUL ALL
RIGHT I SB FIFTY FIVE FIREARMS
PROBATED PERSONS THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND THE REASON I WANTED --
TO PRESENT THIS BILL TODAY.
IS THAT -- I SAW THE ANALYSIS
AND I THINK THERE WE MIGHT HAVE
A SOMEWHAT OF A DISAGREEMENT
ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL DOES AND
DOESN'T.
TO BUT THIS IS A BILL THAT WOULD
PROHIBIT PEOPLE WHO ARE LIKELY
TO ABUSE FIREARMS FROM
POSSESSING THEM.
IT DRAWS ON RESEARCH THAT SHOWS
A STRONG CORRELATION BETWEEN
CERTAIN ALCOHOL AND DRUG RELATED
CONVICTIONS.
AND FUTURE GUN VIOLENCE.
THIS MEASURE ADD SEVERAL CRIMES
AS A RESULT OF THAT RESEARCH TO
THE LIST OF CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS
THAT RESULT IN A TEN YEAR
PROHIBITION ON FIREARM OWNERSHIP.
NOW RESEARCH HAS BEEN CONDUCTED
SINCE.
TWENTY FIFTEEN THROUGH THE
VIOLENCE PREVENTION RESEARCH
PROGRAM AT UC DAVIS AND IT HAS
REVEALED AN IMPORTANT LINK
BETWEEN A CONVICTION FOR AN
ALCOHOL RELATED CRIME.
AND LATER FIREARM ABUSE.
SB FIFTY FIVE TRANSLATE THESE
RESEARCH FINDINGS INTO PUBLIC
POLICY IN AN EFFORT TO PREVENT
GUN VOTE FUTURE GUN VIOLENCE.
BY ADDING SEVERAL RESEARCH
CORRELATED CONVICTIONS. TO THE
LIST OF TEN YEAR PROHIBITIONS OF
GUN POSSESSION -- THEY WILL ADD
TO OUR STATE ARMED AND
PROHIBITED PERSONS LIST THE APPS
LIST.
AND THE COSTS ARE REFLECTED IN
THE ANALYSIS.
BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT THE FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR NUMBER -- DOES
NOT ACCURATELY REFLECT THE
LIKELIHOOD OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
WILL BE SUBJECT TO THIS SO --
THE RESEARCH AT ANTICIPATED
ABOUT FIFTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE PER
YEAR.
WOULD BE.
THEN INCLUDED ON THE PROHIBITED
PERSONS LIST AND I'M VERY HAPPY
TO DISCUSS.
THE PARTIAL -- RETROACTIVITY
ISSUE THAT IS MENTIONED HERE SO
IF WE MADE THIS FULLY
RETROACTIVE I COULD SEE WHERE
YOU MIGHT END UP HAVING TO GO
BACK AND LOOK AT PEOPLE'S
RECORDS AND I COULD SEE THAT IS
A PROBLEM.
IF WE MAKE IT PARTIALLY
RETROACTIVE SO THAT.
IF A PERSON IS PUTTING IN --
TWENTY TWENTY CONVICTED OF A D.
Y..
AND IN THAT RECORD THE COURT
OBSERVED THAT THEY HAVE HAD THE
REQUISITE NUMBER OF PRIOR
CONVICTIONS.
THEN THE COURT WOULD THEN APPLY
THE PROHIBITED PERSONS
RESTRICTION WHICH WOULD THEN BE
REPORTED TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
AT A RATE OF AND NO MORE THAN
FIFTEEN HUNDRED A YEAR A FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR FIGURE SEEMS.
JUST -- OUT OF WHACK IF YOU WILL
SO -- HAPPY TO WORK THROUGH THAT
IF THAT IS INDEED THE BASIS UPON
THAT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR FIGURE
BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT THIS IS --
DOESN'T CORRELATE CERTAINLY WITH
MY EXPECTATIONS AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE BILL DOES
AND DOESN'T DO SO I WOULD LOVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK FURTHER
WITH YOU ON THAT AND SEE IF WE
COULDN'T -- TRY TO COME TO A
NUMBER THAT SEEMS AT LEAST OR IS.
MORE REALISTIC IN TERMS OF WHAT
THE BILL WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO
WITH THE BILL.
I THINK ANY EYEWITNESSES
[inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
YOU HAVE A QUESTION A SURE.
GO AHEAD.
IS IS YOUR DISPUTE OF CENTER
JACKSON WITH THE ACTUAL THE OF
THE FIFTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE WHAT
UNIVERSE WILL BE USING THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER BECAUSE THEY'RE
ACCUSED OF A NEW CRIME BECAUSE
THE VIOLATE THIS TEN EUROPEAN OR
IS IT.
THAT THE IN THE WOULD HAVE THEIR
OWN PRIVATE ATTORNEY OR SET THE
COSTS THAT THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S AND BY THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S WOULD HAVE.
IS A THIS -- BASICALLY WHAT WE
ANTICIPATE IF WE DO A PARTIAL
RETROACTIVITY IS THERE WOULD BE
A NEW OFFENSE.
SO THAT INDIVIDUAL IS GOING TO
HAVE TO HAVE COUNSEL ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER OR WAIVE THE RIGHT TO
COUNSEL.
SO IT'S A NEW OFFENSE THEY'RE
COMING WITH THE
VIOLATED.
OF THE FIREARMS.
AS WELL AS A NEW DO YOU WHY. FOR
INSTANCE RIGHT WELL I THINK
THERE THERE ARE SOME OF THOSE
LOGISTICS WE CAN WORK OUT --
BECAUSE THERE MIGHT BE THERE'S
ARGUABLY A QUESTION ABOUT THEIR
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT WHETHER THEY'RE
VIOLATING THE LAW BUT BUT THEY
WILL ONLY.
IF WE IF WE MAKE THAT ADJUSTMENT
THE THEY WILL ALREADY EITHER
HAVE COUNSEL OF SOME KIND
BECAUSE OF THE NEW OFFENSE.
CLEARLY -- NOT.
PLEASE WORK WITH OUR STAFF TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO BRING
MORE SPECIFICITY.
BECAUSE AS REFLECTED IN THE
ANALYSIS AT SOME OF THE UNKNOWN
FACTORS THE DISCRETIONARY --
COMPONENTS TO THIS THAT MAKE IT
HARD TO DETERMINE HOW MUCH IT'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO COST SO SO A
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE CERTAINLY
OPEN HAVING YOU WORK WITH HER
AFTER TO FIGURE OUT HOW.
TO WE ACTUALLY DO HAVE WITH US
DR KAREN WENT TO MOVE UP NEW TO
IS THE DIRECTOR OF THIS PROGRAM
AT UC DAVIS AND WHO DID THE
RESEARCH ON THIS.
AND PERHAPS IF YOU HAD ANY
QUESTIONS SPECIFICALLY HE'S
PREPARED TO ANSWER IT OR WE CAN
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON RESEARCH.
SO THAT THE GREAT THANK FORGET
THANK YOU.
FOR ALL RIGHT -- ANYONE.
DO YOU HAVE ANYBODY WANTS TO SAY
A BRIEF COMMON IN FAVOR.
OR PERHAPS START TO WIN TO ME TO
YOU CAME ALL THIS WAY YOU KNOW
SAY.
YOU COULD GIVE A BRIEF COMMENT
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
OF COURSE MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY I CAME FROM TEN
MINUTES AWAY I WORK HERE IN
SACRAMENTO I MEANT I MEANT ANY
OUR DOCKET UC DAVIS MEDICAL
CENTER -- SENATOR JACKSON ASKED
ME TO SPEAK BRIEFLY ABOUT THE
THE FISCAL BENEFITS OF ENACTING
SB -- FIFTY FIVE I'VE BROKEN
THIS DOWN INTO GROUPS OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY PEOPLE WHO MIGHT
BECOME PROHIBITED PERSONS BASED
ON DO YOU AYE CONVICTIONS.
I BASS WHAT I'M ABOUT TO SAY ON
DATA WE HAVE COLLECTED ON MORE
THAN EIGHTY THOUSAND LEGAL
PURCHASERS OF FIREARMS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
OUR ESTIMATE BASED ON THOSE REAL
DATA.
IS THAT EACH GROUP OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY PERSONS UNDER
CURRENT CONDITIONS IF NOTHING
WERE DONE -- IN EACH GROUP ON
AVERAGE THIRTY SEVEN WOULD BE
ARRESTED SUBSEQUENTLY FOR A
VIOLENT CRIME. TWENTY TWO FOR A
VIOLENT CRIME INVOLVING A
FIREARM SEVEN FOR HOMICIDE RAPE
ROBBERY OR AGGRAVATED ASSAULT WE
ALSO KNOW FROM OUR PRIOR
RESEARCH THAT THIS SORT OF
PROGRAM.
REDUCES THAT RISK BY 25230%.
IT'S WORTH POINTING OUT THAT THE
COST TO DIRECTLY TO GOVERNMENT
OF A SINGLE FIREARM HOMICIDE IS
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THE TOTAL SOCIETAL COSTS.
OUR SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS PREVENTING JUST A SMALL
NUMBER OF THESE CRIMES WOULD
COMPLETELY OFFSET THE COST OF
EXPANDING THE PROHIBITION.
THANK YOU -- OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MR TURN MEMBERS SYLVIA SOLUTION
ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES CITY
ATTORNEY MIKE IF YOU'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MIKE SKIP ON BEHALF OF ALCOHOL
JUSTICE IN THE CALIFORNIA
ALCOHOL POLICY ALLIANCE WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND BELIEVE WILL HELP TO REDUCE
STATES FOURTEEN POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR PER YEAR COSTS OF
ALCOHOL RELATED HARM THANK YOU.
I CAN'T CORAIL ON ON BEHALF OF
THE CELL SACRAMENTO.
SENIOR CITIZENS ALLIANCE WE ARE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF ANYTHING
THAT WILL REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE
AND THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
MEASURES THANK YOU.
USE ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAMPRAS
REPRESENTING GUN OWNERS
CALIFORNIA -- AS AS IT'S BEEN
POINTED OUT WE HAVE GREAT
CONCERNS ABOUT THE WHOLE CONCEPT
THE PRE CRIME.
AND AND GOVERNMENT GOING AFTER
PEOPLE WHO THEY THINK MIGHT
GROUP COMMIT A CRIME SOMETIME IN
THE FUTURE.
THE PHYSICAL ASPECT OF THIS IS
THIS WOULD LIKE TO REMIND THE
COMMITTEE THAT -- THIS COMMITTEE
ACTUALLY AUTHORIZED TWENTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO BRING
THE APPS.
NUMBERS DOWN.
AND IN FACT THEY BROUGHT IT DOWN
FOR AWHILE WE'RE BACK OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE ON THAT
LIST.
THIS IS GOING TO THE ESTIMATES
OF WHAT IT'S GOING TO COST. TO
CHECK THE PEOPLE THAT ARE ON THE
APPS I THINK IS IS PRETTY --
CONSERVATIVE IN WILL PROBABLY
END UP BEING SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
EXPENSIVE SO FOR THOSE REASONS
GUNNERS CALIFORNIA'S IN
OPPOSITION.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LIKE ME RIGHT
GRIFFIS BECOME HAPPY CALIFORNIA
RIFLE PISTOL ASSOCIATION WERE
ALSO IN OPPOSITION MOSTLY FOR
THE ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBLY
PLACED ON LAW ENFORCEMENT CLOSE
FINANCIAL BURDENS TAKEN THEIR
ATTENTION AWAY FROM TRUE VIOLENT
CRIMINALS THAT NEED TO BE TAKEN
OFF OUR STREETS.
AT THE SAME TIME THAT BILLS ARE
GOING THROUGH THIS BUILDING THAT
REDUCE THOSE PENALTIES ON KNOWN
VIOLENT CRIMINALS.
LIKE SB SIX TWENTY A COUPLE
YEARS AGO AND SO FORTH WE NEED
TO FOCUS OUR ATTENTION ON KNOWN
VIOLENT CRIMINALS AND NOT.
A MISDEMEANOR FOLKS MAKING
MISTAKES THANK YOU THANK YOU
JUST FINANCE HAVE A FILE.
THE FILE FILE MISS JACKSON WOULD
YOU LIKE.
TO MAKE A CLOSING COMMENT IN.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES -- THE FACT
THAT THE ABSOLUTE STEWS IS NOT
COMPLETED I BELIEVE THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS RECOGNIZED THIS AND
THAT THERE HAS BEEN AND THAT THE
THIS COMMITTEE ALSO WAS AGREED
TO ADD ADDITIONAL FUNDS.
THAT'S NO REASON NOT TO TRY TO
PROTECT AGAINST FUTURE GUN
VIOLENCE THIS THE MEASURE IS
BASED UPON ACTUAL RESEARCH.
AND FOR YEARS MANY OF US HAVE
HYPOTHESIZED AND THE THROUGH --
ANECDOTAL INFORMATION WE BELIEVE
CERTAIN THINGS WE FINALLY IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN ACTUALLY PUT
MONEY INTO CREATING A RESEARCH.
FACILITY TO LOOK AT GUN VIOLENCE
THE RESULTS ARE THE ARE
REFLECTED IN THIS BILL WE KNOW
THAT PEOPLE.
WHO HAVE?
DEMONSTRATED THE INABILITY TO
MAKE GOOD JUDGMENTS AND HAD
THREE OR MORE.
A D. Y. CONVICTIONS AND OTHER
ALCOHOL TYPE RELATED OFFENSES.
DURING THE PAST TEN YEARS OR
FOUR TO FIVE TIMES MORE LIKELY.
TO USE A FIREARM IN A FUTURE
CRIMINAL ACT THAT IS THE
RESEARCH THAT IS UNCONTROVERTED
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO AS WAS
JUST ARTICULATED IS TO PREVENT
THE COST NOT ONLY THE SOCIAL
COSTS BUT THE FISCAL COST TO
SOCIETY.
AND AGAIN I DON'T THINK FIVE
MILLION IS AN ACCURATE NUMBER
BUT WHATEVER THAT NUMBER IS IS
FAR LESS THAN THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE KIND OF
VIOLENCE THAT WE SEE FROM THESE
PEOPLE.
WHO ARE HAVE THE GREATER
PROPENSITY TO BEHAVE IN A WAY
THAT INFLICTS FIREARM BASED HARM
ON OTHERS AND WITHOUT -- I WOULD
TO A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND I WOULD BE
DELIGHTED TO CONTINUE WRKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE
SO THAT WE CAN MAKE THIS HAPPEN
UNDER FOUR THANK YOU SEEING NO
OTHER QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FIFTY FIVE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE.
SB ONE SIXTY EMERGENCIES
CULTURAL COMPETENCE IS ALSO A
SUSPENSE.
ITEM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF THIS
MEASURE I JUST WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU BECAUSE IT IS
A BILL THAT DIRECTS COUNTIES TO
INTEGRATE THE NEEDS.
OF CULTURALLY DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES INTO THE NEXT UPDATE
OF THEIR COUNTY EMERGENCY PLANS.
AS WE SEE CLIMATE CHANGE AND
WILDFIRES IN MAJOR AND DRAMATIC.
EVENTS OCCURRING THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE OUR NATION AND INDEED OUR
WORLD.
IT IS CLEAR THAT WE NEED TO DO
BETTER TO ADDRESS COMMUNITIES
WHO OTHERWISE ARE NOT PROVIDED
WITH THE NECESSARY INFORMATION.
OR PROTECTIONS WHEN THESE EVENTS
OCCUR.
DURING A HEARING OF OUR JOINT
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT JUST A FEW
MONTHS AGO THE POINT WAS MADE
THAT IT'S NOT ENOUGH FOR
COUNTIES TO HAVE A STAFF MEMBER
PROFICIENT.
IN A LANGUAGE THAT IS
SIGNIFICANT WITHIN A COMMUNITY
IT ALSO REQUIRES THE COUNTY TO
HAVE A COMPLEMENTARY AND
COMPREHENSIVE UNDERSTANDING OF
THE CULTURAL AND SOCIAL THE
DYNAMICS OF THAT COMMUNITY WHICH
WE REFER TO AS CULTURAL
COMPETENCE.
SO THIS MEASURE WILL REQUIRE
LOCAL EMERGENCY PLANS TO
COLLABORATE WITH QUALIFIED
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS AND
STAKEHOLDERS IN ORDER TO DISCUSS
AT A MINIMUM.
HOW ALL CULTURAL POPULATIONS
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTION ARE
SERVED BY EMERGENCY
COMMUNICATIONS EVACUATIONS AND
SHELTERING MITIGATION PREVENTION
PLANNING AND PREPAREDNESS AND
THE EXAMPLE I LIKE TO USE TO
SORT OF GIVE YOU A SENSE?
OF HOW THIS DOES AND DOESN'T
WORK IS DURING THE THOMAS FIRE
WHICH OCCURRED IN MY DISTRICT.
A LITTLE OVER A YEAR AGO OF A
FIRE STORM THAT OCCURRED OVER
THE COURSE OF FORTY DAYS.
TOOK OUT ALMOST THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES IN WAS UNTIL THE
FIRES THIS YEAR THE LARGEST FIRE
IN THE HISTORY CALIFORNIA.
THE WAY IT WAS.
UNUSUALLY EXPLAINED TO THE
SPANISH SPEAKING COMMUNITY USING
GOOGLE TRANSLATION WAS THAT
THERE WAS A HAIR BRUSH FIRE
[inaudible]
GOING ON CLEARLY WE HAVE TO DO
BETTER.
IN WARNING PEOPLE IN EXPLAINING
TO THEM WHAT'S GOING ON IN
ADDRESSING.
HOW VARIOUS COMMUNITIES CAN
PROTECT THEMSELVES PROTECT THE
COMMUNITY WHEN THESE EVENTS
HAPPENED?
I NOTE THAT THE CUMULATIVE COSTS
ARE ESTIMATED TO EXCEED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT IS.
PROBABLY CORRECT I DON'T THINK
ANYONE'S QUITE SURE WHAT IT
WOULD BE BUT AGAIN IN TERMS OF
SAVING LIVES PROTECTING PROPERTY --
I FEEL THAT THIS IS A MEASURE
THAT.
DOES -- CALL OUT FOR THE KIND OF
SERIOUS CONSIDERATION THAT I
KNOW THIS COMMITTEE WILL GIVE.
CAN YOU HAVE WITNESSES WHO WANT
TO SAY BRIEF COMMONER.
THE MORNING CHAIR PORTANTINO AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SYLVIA I DON'T KNOW I'M WITH
COMMUNITIES FOR A BETTER
ENVIRONMENT THE CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
COORDINATOR.
A C. B. E. BILLS PEOPLE'S POWER
ACROSS CALIFORNIA'S -- LOW
INCOME AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
TO ACHIEVE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE --
WE ARE A MEMBER ORGANIZATION OF
THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ALLIANCE A COSPONSOR OF
THIS BILL ALONG SIDE THE WOMEN'S
POLICY INSTITUTE WOMEN'S
FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIA.
I IN ADDITION TO SENATOR
JACKSON'S COMMENTS WE URGE YOU.
TO VOTE YES ON SB ONE SIXTY SO
THAT LOCAL COUNTIES -- CAN
STRENGTHEN THEIR EMERGENCY
EXISTING EMERGENCY PROTOCOLS --
AND IT'S REALLY AS ADDRESSING AN
ESPECIALLY THE NEEDS OF
CULTURALLY DIVERSE COMMUNITIES --
SO THAT WE SAFEGUARD AND PROTECT --
THESE FOLKS FROM THE INCREASING
THREATS OF DISASTERS FIELD BY
CLIMATE CHANGE.
WE ARE WORKING WITH -- CALLOW
YES AND LOCAL COUNTIES TO
UNDERSTAND THE EXISTING
ENGAGEMENT LEVELS -- WHEN THEY
ARE PRODUCING EMERGENCY PLANS
AND HOW COUNTIES CAN LEVERAGE
EXISTING -- FUNDING SOURCES AND
SO JUST YOU KNOW ABOUT A MONTH
AGO THROUGH AB SEVENTY TWO GET
THE NEWSOM.
ANNOUNCED FIFTY MILLION --
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS CAMPAIGN
AND THIS IS SPECIFICALLY
TARGETING OF VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES TO BOLSTER AND
INCORPORATE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT --
AND SO WE DON'T ENGAGE
CULTURALLY DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
IN THIS PROCESS OF EMERGENCY
PLANNING -- YOU KNOW SOMETIMES
ARE PRODUCING AN EFFECTIVE PLANS --
WHICH ARE EVIDENT FROM THE
DISHEARTENING STORIES THAT WERE
COMING OUT OF THE RECORD
BREAKING THE WILD FIRES A SO SB
ONE SIXTY RESPONSE. TO THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF OUR COUNTIES AND
ULTIMATELY PROTECT THE SAFETY OF
EVERYONE SO THANK YOU -- FOR THE
TIME AND I RESPECTED
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
YES GOOD MORNING -- CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S TINA
ROBINSON LOCAL POLICY ASSOCIATE
WITH THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK.
WE WORK WITH ASIAN AMERICAN
IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE
COMMUNITIES.
IN THE BAY AREA MANY OF WHOM
HAVE LOW EDUCATION LEVELS AND
LOW ENGLISH PROFICIENCY AND HAVE
TO DEAL WITH -- FOR EXAMPLE THE
CHEVRON -- FINDING IT THE
LARGEST DISTRIBUTOR IN THE STATE --
JUST HAD MULTIPLE ACCIDENTS AND
EXPLOSIONS -- AND HAVE WORKED
WITH THEM -- TO DEAL WITH THE
EMERGENCY PLANS -- SB ONE SIXTY
A SOUND POLICY THAT SEES THE
IMMINENCE OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
NATURAL DISASTERS AND OFFERS A
PROACTIVE AND INCLUSIVE MEASURE.
TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES ARE PART OF PLANNING
FOR THE FUTURE.
OF CALIFORNIA'S FRIENDLY
COMMUNITIES ARE INFORMS PREPARED
AND ENGAGED NOW IT REDUCES THE
COST AND RISK FOR ALL WHEN
EMERGENCY STRIKES.
PREVENTION AND MITIGATION ARE
ALWAYS MORE COST EFFECTIVE THAN
AN UNFORESEEN PROBLEM OR
UNEXPECTED AFTERMATH.
AND COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT DOES
NOT REQUIRE EXPENSIVE TECHNOLOGY
AT RISK TO FIRST RESPONDERS OR
OVERTIME FOR HEALTH CARE WORKERS.
CREATING A STANDARD FOR
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT THAT HELPS
COUNTIES ACHIEVE CULTURAL
COMPETENCY AND THEIR SPECIFIC
DEMOGRAPHIC AND GEOGRAPHIC NEEDS
IS A COMMON SENSE INVESTMENT
INTO A SAFER MORE PREPARED
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS WANT TO JUST SAY ME TO
PLACE.
MORNING -- THIS IS DAN OF US
BECAUSE OF POLICY MANAGER FOR
CALIFORNIA ROOMS JUST ELAINE
STRONG COSPONSORED THE BILL BEEN
ALSO NO REGISTER SUPPORT FOR THE
CENTER REYES PROPERTY NUMBER.
THINKING.
HI I'M SYLVIA CHIEF FROM THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL
NETWORK AND I ALSO WANT TO
REGISTER STRONG SUPPORT FROM
BECAUSE CENTRAL COAST ALLIANCE.
UNITED FOR SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY.
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE THIS FINANCE HAVE A
FILE NO FILE FILE SEEN --
QUESTIONS MISS JACKSON YOU WANT
TO MAKE A QUICK CLOSE BURKE
QUICKLY TRISTA FOCUSING ON THE
FACT THAT WE REALLY NEED TO
STRENGTHEN OUR EMERGENCY
PROTOCOLS THIS IS A WAY TO MAKE
SURE WE CAN DO THAT SO.
RECOGNIZING ITS AS SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST CONSIDERATION IS A CAUSE.
FOR THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB ONE SIXTY WE'RE GONNA
SUSPENSE YOU'RE WAITING
PRESENTATION ON SB.
ONE SEVEN ONE REMOVED SB THREE
FORTY SIX AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
SO -- THIS IS. ONE OF THOSE
KINDS OF MEASURES THAT WAS.
CREATED AS A MARKET BASED TYPE
OF PROGRAM WITH THE ASSISTANCE
OF THE YMCA.
WE BROUGHT THIS MEASURE IN --
TWENTY FOURTEEN A CALL THE DASH
DISTINGUISHED AFTER SCHOOL
HEALTH.
AND IT IS A PROGRAM THAT
RECOGNIZES AFTER SCHOOL.
PROGRAMS PROMOTING HEALTHY DIETS
AND EXERCISE.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE MORE
THAN 38% OF THE CHILDREN OF THIS
STATE ARE CONSIDERED TO BE
EITHER OVERWEIGHT OR OBESE.
WE KNOW THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT IN TERMS OF HEALTH
ISSUES AS THESE ARE CHILDREN AS
THEY GROW.
WHETHER IT'S THE DIABETES HEART
DISEASE AND TRUST THE GENERAL
MALAISE OF OBESITY.
SO THE DASH PROGRAM.
ATTEMPTS TO CREATE GOOD HABITS
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IN THESE AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS BY REQUIRING
REGULAR IN ONGOING NUTRITION
EDUCATION.
HAVE A REQUIRES AN AVERAGE OF
THIRTY TO SIXTY MINUTES TO DALY
OF PHYSICAL ACTIVITY.
LIMITED TIME SPENT IN FRONT OF
TELEVISION AND COMPUTER SCREENS
AND ONLY FOR EDUCATIONAL
PURPOSES.
PROVIDES ONLY HEALTHY FOOD
OPTIONS INCLUDING FOODS
VEGETABLES SNACKS AND BEVERAGES
THAT DO NOT HAVE ANY ADDED
SUGARS.
AND SAFE AND HEALTHY DRINKING
WATERS THE PRIMARY.
SOURCE OF REFRESHMENT DURING
THESE PROGRAMS THIS MAY SEEM
LIKE SORT OF BASIC STUFF.
BUT THESE ARE AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE DESIGNED TO
HELP YOUNG PEOPLE DEVELOP BETTER
HABITS AND WHAT'S INTERESTING
ABOUT THESE PROGRAMS IS THEIR
SELF RECOGNIZED.
IF I RUN AN AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO BE DASH
CERTIFIED I MAKE THAT
APPLICATION.
I IDENTIFY WHAT CALLING MEETING
THOSE REQUIREMENTS AND IN ITS
FIRST TWO YEARS OVER A HUNDRED
NINETY AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
SOUGHT AND RECEIVED THE STASHED
CERTIFICATION FROM SHASTA COUNTY
DOWN TO SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
THIS IS A VERY COST EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM TO TEACH GOOD HABITS TO
YOUNG PEOPLE AND ASSURE THAT OUR
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS PROVIDE
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES.
AND SO WITH ME I HAVE ALESSANDRO
ESPINOZA FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS --
IN A I THINK IT WAS -- LAST YEAR --
THE DEPARTMENT OF ED AND
ESTIMATED OR ACTUALLY NOW
CURRENTLY I BELIEVE THEY
ESTIMATE THAT THEY'LL BE
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
NECESSARY EQUIVALENT OF ONE
POINT ONE POSITIONS. TO RE
ESTABLISH AND IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM WHICH HAS EXPIRED.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ALEJANDRO IT'S BEEN ALSO
ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION AND COSPONSORED TONY
THURMOND.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE THE
AUTHOR THE SENATOR FOR BRINGING
THIS PROGRAM FORWARD -- WE'RE
VERY EXCITED -- FOR THE
POSSIBILITY OF RE ESTABLISHING
THE DASH AS THE CENTER HAD
MENTIONED -- IN IN THE FIRST
YEAR WE HAD JUST ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED SITES BE RECOGNIZED.
OF THE SUPERINTENDENT BELIEVES
IN IN ADDRESSING THE WHOLE CHILD
IN ADDITION TO PROVIDING THE
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES THAT --
THE THE SUPERINTENDENT BELIEVES
THAT.
SCHOOL SHOULD ALSO OFFER HEALTHY
PROMOTE HEALTHY BEHAVIORS AND
I'LL PROVIDE STUDENTS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PHYSICAL
ACTIVITY.
AND SO WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
SENATOR -- LOOKING FORWARD TO
BUILDING OFF THE SUCCESS BACK
FROM -- TWENTY SIXTEEN IN AGAIN
THANK THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND WITH
THAT I'LL REQUEST THAT I ANY
OTHER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
ANYBODY OPPOSED.
FINANCE THE FILE.
NO FILE.
AS A CLOSER MIGHT INDICATE THAT
THIS WHOLE VISION STARTED AT THE
YMCA IN BURBANK.
RECOUNT.
WE LOVE BURBANK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER ALL SB. FORTY SIX WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL GO TO SUSPENSE --
SB ONE SEVENTY ONE IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR
OF MISTER JACKSON'S ONE SEVENTY
ONE ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB ONE SEVEN ONE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE AS WELL.
THANK YOU -- I DON'T SEE ANY
OTHER AUTHORS SO SB.
SIXTY ONE PORTANTINO FIREARM
TRANSFERS -- TO WERE LOWER I'M
SORRY.
I'M GONNA GO BACK TO CAMP.
ZERO SB FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR CARRIER -- WATER ARIEL
SNOW SERVING ANYBODY HERE.
FOR FORTY SEVEN COME ON UP.
HI MY NAME IS ALEX BRING THEM
FROM FRONT WATER AUTHORITY -- I
JUST WANT TO MAKE A FEW COMMENTS
TO TO LET YOU KNOW ABOUT THE
BENEFITS THAT WE PROJECT THAT
THIS BILL COULD POTENTIALLY
BRING FOR WATER SUPPLY FLOOD
RISK AND ECOSYSTEM RESTORATION
THE STATE -- SO WE UNDERSTAND
THAT IT'S A PRETTY BIG NUMBER
THAT SEND THAT BILL AND I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT A COUPLE OF
THINGS.
SO BASED ON AS AN EXAMPLE BASED
ON THE PRELIMINARY ESTIMATES WE
HAVE IN THE SAN JOAQUIN BASIN
WE'RE LOOKING AT ABOUT FIFTEEN
TO FORTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
WATER SUPPLY SAVINGS PER YEAR --
EXTRAPOLATED TO THE ENTIRE
ENTIRE SNOW COVERED AREAS OF
THIS BILL LOOKS AT THAT COULD BE
AS MUCH AS THREE HUNDRED TO SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
SOLELY ON WATER SUPPLY BENEFITS
THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE HIGHER
POWER.
OR ECOSYSTEM RESTORATION OF
FLOOD RISK REDUCTION -- ON THE
ECOSYSTEM RESTORATION SIDE WERE
NOTICING IN THE FOR EACH
ADDITIONAL ECOSYSTEM FLOWS FOR
SALMON RESTORATION OF THE RIVER
WE'RE LOOKING AT ABOUT ONE POINT
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
OR MILLION.
DOLLARS IN SAVINGS PRAYER FOR
THOSE ADDITIONAL FLOWS SO WE
THINK THERE'S A PRETTY BIG VALUE
HERE ON THE FLOOD RISK SIDE IT'S
HARD TO ESTIMATE EXACTLY WHAT
THE BENEFITS ARE BUT THERE'S
MILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN -- DAMAGES THAT COULD HAPPEN
ANY THE WATERSHED CENTER -- AT
THE WITHIN THE SNOW COVERED AREA
SURVEYS AS WELL SO WE THINK
THERE'S A HIGH VALUE EVEN THOUGH
THAT FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR IS IS QUITE A LARGE NUMBER
SO.
JUST WANT TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU
GUYS THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NOW SEE NO QUESTIONS --
SB FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB.
SIX TWENTY EIGHT I'M SORRY
FINANCE.
WE DON'T HAVE APPROVED POSITION
ON THIS BILL BUT NOTE THAT THE
IT GETS CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATE
CENTER AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND.
REQUIRES A FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS OF THAT -- APPROPRIATION
TO BE ALLOCATED FOR EXPENDITURE
EACH FISCAL YEAR.
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES ESTIMATES THE BILL
WILL REQUIRE TWO POSITIONS TO
PROVIDE PROJECT COORDINATION AND
CONTRACT OVERSIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR THE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN
GOES TO SUSPENSE SB.
SIX TWENTY EIGHT MISS CAVELL
AERO PRINDLE BYPASS ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION FINANCE.
AGAIN A NO A POSITION -- BUT
WOULD NOT THE BLL MAY REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING AVAILABLE
FOR REIMBURSEMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION DEBT SERVICE
COSTS.
BY UP TO SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IF CALTRANS USES
ITS AUTHORITY TO SELL THE EXCESS
PROPERTIES.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL COULD
RESULT IN ONE TIME COSTS FOR
CALTRANS TO BRING THE HIGHWAY
SEGMENT PROPOSED FOR
RELINQUISHMENT INTO A STATE OF
GOOD REPAIR -- THIS COULD RESULT
ALSO AND LONG TERM -- COST
SAVINGS TO THE STATE FOR
DECREASING ONGOING MEANS
WORKLOAD.
THANK YOU ARE SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SIX
TWENTY EIGHT COACH TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON TO MISTER ROGERS -- SB
TWENTY NINE MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY.
ANYBODY HERE IN SUPPORT.
ALEX TO CAPRI ON BEHALF OF
RESPECT CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THE PHILLIES SOLUTION ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN THE OFFICE OF
MARYLAND AND BREED THANK YOU.
FOR MICHELLE GIVENS WITH THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIANS PARK.
REAL WELL ON BEHALF OF
INDIVISIBLE SUCK MIDDLE AND
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA STRONG
[inaudible]
IN SUPPORT.
MICHELLE CAPITA WITH SEIU
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
YES MEAN CODE WITH HELP ACCESS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE FINANCE NO FILE FILE
ANY QUESTIONS SEEING NINE SB
TWENTY NINE GOES TO SUSPENSE.
SB THREE SEVEN FIVE MR RAZA
VICTIMS OF CRIME.
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OF THREE
SEVEN FIVE THE MORNING DEANGELO
MAC WITH PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION.
FINANCING FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THREE SEVEN
FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE I SEE
MISTER MINING.
CAME IN YOU HAVE ONE ITEM IT'S A
SUSPENSE [inaudible]
CANDIDATE [inaudible]
SINCE KENNEDY.
STATE HIGHWAY ONE SB.
FIVE OH FOUR YES THE SAME ENGINE
MANAGER CHAIR DID YOU KNOW THAT
ARE NOT KNOW THAT I DIDN'T KNOW
THAT I HAVE A VERY SHORT
STATEMENT KNOWN ONE WITNESS IT
FLEES BE BRIEF.
THANKS THIS WILL BE THE BRIEFEST
YOU'VE HEARD ALL MORNING.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SENATE BILL
FIVE OH FOUR AUTHORIZES THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION TO RELINQUISH TO THE
CITY OF HIS M<c.cyan> BEACH. TWO</c>
POINT FIVE MILES OF STATE
HIGHWAY ROUTE ONE THAT ARE
WITHIN THE CITY LIMITS.
HAVE RICHARD HERMAN HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF HIS M<c.cyan></c>
BEACH IN SUPPORT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I WOULD ASK FOR
MEMBERS -- VOTE.
RICHARD DOMINO WE HAVE
CONSIDERED GIVES A BUSINESS EACH
SPONSORING SUPPORTER OF THE BILL.
I LIKE THAT ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN A SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION.
FINANCED YOU HAVE A FILE IN SB.
FIVE OH FOUR THANK YOU.
FINANCES NEUTRAL AND IT FINANCES
NEUTRONS MEASURE THANK YOU
FINANCES NEUTRAL WHEN IF I MIGHT
JUST IN A BRIEF CLOSE SITE THAT --
ESTIMATED COSTS OF THE CALTRANS
PROJECT TO BRING THIS SEGMENT
INTO GOOD REPAIR.
THIS IS A SUNKEN COST CALTRANS
IS ALREADY DOING THAT PROJECT
WITH OR WITHOUT A RELINQUISHMENT.
SO THAT WOULD BE THE KEY POINT
TO MAKE IN TERMS OF COST THE
STATE IT'S ALREADY.
INCURRING THE COST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SORRY FOR
THE MIX UP NO IT'S ALRIGHT
APPRECIATE IT AND WE'LL LOOK
FORWARD TO THE AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB.
FIVE OH FOUR WHEELERS SUSPENSE.
SEEING NO OTHER AUTHORS WILL GO
TO MISTER WIENER SB.
THIRTY FOUR CANNABIS DONAIONS
ANY SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION OF WITH THE SAID
ON THAT SIDE.
TURN MEMBER SYLVIA'S ALICIA ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO OFFICE OF MARYLAND
IN BRITAIN SUPPORT.
AREN'T ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION.
PASSING ON FINANCE THE FILE NO
FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THIRTY
FOUR FOUR GO TO SUSPENSE SB.
FIFTY EIGHT MISTER WINNER
ALCOHOL BEVERAGE HOURS OF SALES
OR ANYBODY HERE IN SUPPORT.
SB.
FIFTY EIGHT SYLVIA SOLUTION ON
BEHALF OF CITY OF LOS ANGELES
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IN SUPPORT
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF AT
MARYLAND TO BREED IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ANY OPPOSITION SB.
FIFTY EIGHT MICHAEL SKIPPER FOR
ALCOHOL JUSTICE IN THE
CALIFORNIA ALCOHOL POLICY
ALLIANCE -- WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL WE FEEL THAT IT WILL
JUST ADD.
TO THE AVAILABILITY AND THE HARM
DONE -- BY ALCOHOL.
IN THE EARLY MORNING HOURS IN
THE COSTS WILL BE FAR GREATER
THAN THE EXPECTED REVENUE THANK
YOU.
FINANCE NO FILE.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS ON SB FIFTY
EIGHT THAT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWO SIXTY
EIGHT BY MISTER WINNER ON CAL
WORKS ELIGIBILITY.
ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
BECAUSE THE CHRISTIANSEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
FINANCE THE FILE FILE SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP SB TWO SIX EIGHT ON
CAL WORKS WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
MISTER HILLS BILLS SB THIRTY
EIGHT FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS
IS THERE.
ANYBODY WANTS TO SPEAK IN FAVOR
[inaudible]
IN OPPOSITION.
FINANCE THE FILE SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP SB THIRTY EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
SB -- TWO TO ONE MISTER HILL LAW
ENFORCEMENT FIREARMS ACCOUNTING
IS THEIR SUPPORT.
DANIEL CANDOR KAISER ON BEHALF
OF THE GIFFORDS LAWCENTER IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THEIR OPPOSITION.
FINANCE NO FILE.
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP SB TWO TWO
ONE WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THREE SIXTY MISTER
HILL MANDATED REPORTERS
[inaudible]
SENATE SUPPORT.
BARRY HIRED CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
ROGER VALLEY'S CARS IN SUPPORT.
KAREN BENTLEY SCARS INSOFAR
[inaudible]
SIR OPPOSITION.
OPPOSITION FINANCE SO FILE NO
FINAL.
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP SB.
THREE SIXTY HELLO.
WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE.
I SEE MISTER MCGUIRE CAME IN AND
YOU ARE HERE.
WITH ONE TO PASS AND YOU HAVE
NICELY WAY PRESENTATION ON THE
OTHER.
TWO PLEASE COME UP AND TELL US
ABOUT SB FOUR FOUR NINE ON PEST
CONTROL.
PIERCE'S DISEASE THAT'S RIGHT.
WATCH OUT.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR HOPE EVERYONE
ENJOYED THEIR HOLIDAY IN IT'S
GOOD TO SEE EVERYONE BACK IN
PROCEED TO OPPORTUNITY MISTER
CHAIR TO BED PRESENT SP FOUR
FOUR NINE AS YOU STATED WE'RE
GONNA BE WAITING PRESENTATION SB.
FIVE TWENTY THREE SB SIX THIRTY
SEVEN CALIFORNIA MAKES 81% OF
ALL WINE IN AMERICA AND WE ARE
PROBABLY THE WORLD'S FOURTH
LEADING LINE PRODUCER.
PIERCE'S DISEASE IS SPREAD BY A
NIGHT AND NASTY LITTLE ****
CALLED THE SHARPSHOOTER IN WANT
TO BIND IS INFECTED THE DISEASE
WILL BLOCK THE WATER SYSTEM THE
PLANT THE FRUIT WILL SHRIVEL IN
BOTH THE LEASE AND THE FRUIT
WILL DIE.
THIS IS A SERIOUS CHALLENGE ONE
OF THE MOST SERIOUS CHALLENGES
FOR A BIT A CULTURE INDUSTRY
HERE IN THE GOLDEN STATE.
SB FOUR FOUR NINE EXTENDS THE
THE PIERCE'S DISEASE CONTROL
PROGRAM TO TWENTY TWENTY SIX TO
CONTINUE IMPORTANT RESEARCH
EFFORT TO COMBAT THIS
DEVASTATING DISEASE IN CODIFIES.
FINDING GIVEN THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA FOR THE PURPOSE OF
CONDUCTING RESEARCH IN WILL NOT
BE USED TOWARD INTERACT OR
OVERHEAD COSTS SUCH AS
FACILITIES WERE MINISTRY OF COST.
THE ANNUAL FISCAL COST OF THIS
BEFORE FOUR NINE ARE FULLY
FUNDED BY FEDERAL FUNDS IN
INDUSTRY ASSESSMENTS I HAVE WITH
ME TODAY THE MAN THE MYTH THE
MAN THE MILLER.
MISTER MICHAEL MILLER -- FROM
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION ONE
GROUP GRAPE GROWERS IN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AT THE MOST APPROPRIATE
TIME.
THANK YOU.BUT WHEN AS MICHAEL MILLER WITH
THE COMPANY'S DECISION WINE
GRAPE GROWERS OF THE PITCHES
DISEASE CONTROL PROGRAM IS
CRITICAL TO THE HELP
CALIFORNIA'S WINE GRAPES WE ARE
STRONGLY SUPPORTED BUILD THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR ALL THREE THE
BILL.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
A GOOD MORNING TYLER LACKEY WITH
THE WINE INSTITUTE HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MELISSA WARNER WITH
THE FAMILY Y. MAKERS OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
ANY OPPOSITION.
FINANCE NO FILE NO FILE IT IS A
SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH
SIDES WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE WITH
RESPECT FASTER I GO TO THE
pCHAIR.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION ANY
QUESTIONS HE BEACH A BY A SMIDGE.
ALL RIGHT THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO PASS SENTENCE BEFORE FOUR
NINE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HI HILL [inaudible]
JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY WE CASKEY AYE.
THAT BILLS GOT FIVE VOTES WILL
KEEP IT ON CALL FOR MISTER HILL
AND MISTER -- MISTER JONES IS
HERE THEY ARE OUR USE.
GOOD TO SEE -- AND WELCOME BACK
I'M SORRY.
I KNOW -- SEEMS LIKE YESTERDAY.
WITH THAT WE WILL GO BACK TO I
GUESS IT'S ME -- SB SIXTY ONE
PORTANTINO FIREARMS.
I DON'T SEE ANYBODY IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION.
FINANCE THE FILE NO FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SIXTY ONE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE.
SB THREE SEVEN SIX PORTANTINO
FIREARMS WHAT.
BOBBI GUYS WANTED TO COME UP.
GOT TO MOVE FAST.
COME ON OUT.
IF YOU WANT TO TALK ON SIXTY ONE
ALL RIGHT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD AND
RE ATTACH RIGHTFUL ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION -- STICKING IN THE
FISCALASPECTS OF THIS THIS WILL
IMPACT LAW ABIDING CITIZENS
CAUSING THEM TO SPEND MORE MONEY
ON BACKGROUND CHECK FEES SIX
CETERA ADDITIONAL TRIPS TO THE
FARM STORE.
TO PURCHASE LONG GUNS CRIMINALS
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO ACT OUT
ACT OUTSIDE THE SYSTEM --
ADDITIONALLY THOSE FEES ARE
LOOKING TO BE REYES THIS YEAR
THERE SEVERAL BILLS INCLUDING
EXCISE TAXES AS WELL AS RAISING
THE DRUGS FEES.
FURTHER DOJ IS STILL HAVING
TROUBLE IMPLEMENTING SOME OF THE
LEGISLATION THAT HAS BEEN PASSED
THROUGH THIS INCLUDING
AMMUNITION BACKGROUND CHECKS.
OF THE REGULATIONS FOR THAT ARE
STILL PENDING IN JULY FIRST AS
OPPOSED TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
DATE THIS IS ONE MORE THING BUT
ON THE PLATE THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ARE A GOOD
FIT FOR THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
PISTOL ASSOCIATION STANDING IN
OPPOSITION FOR THE FINANCIAL
PURPOSE OF PEOPLE ROBSON DOLLARS
LOST FOR THE MANTA MONIES THAT
COME INTO THE STATE FOR WILDLIFE
MANAGEMENT PURPOSES ANOTHER GOOD
USES.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAMPRAS
REPRESENT GUN WAS A CALIFORNIA
ME [inaudible]
TOO THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER SPEAKERS AND NO
REPORT SB SIXTY ONE WILL GO --
TO SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
THREE SEVEN SIX PORTANTINO
FIREARM TRANSFERS.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
IT'S THEIR OPPOSITION.
NOT COMING BACK ON THAT ONE OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NO OTHER HANDS
GO UP FINANCE THE FILE NO FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THREE SEVEN
SIX WILL GO THE SUSPENSE.
AS FOUR EIGHTY FOUR PORTANTINO
COMMITTEE COLLEGE TRANSFERS
[inaudible]
ANY SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION FILE.
NO FILE NO FINAL SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP.
SB FOUR EIGHT FOUR WILL GO THE
SUSPENSE SB SEVENTY TWO BY MR
UMBERG.
ON PROVISIONAL BALLOTS IS THERE
ANY SUPPORT OPPOSITION UP COME
ON UP [inaudible]
INDIVISIBLE.
THE VOTERS WE LIKE THEM.
TO BUT MY NAME IS CáC REAL AND
I DO REGISTER MY SUPPORT -- ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS.
THANK YOU.
ANY OPPOSITION FINANCE THE FILE
NO FILE SEEING NO HANDS GO UP.
SB SEVENTY TWO WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WEBER SNEEZE COMPETITION.
I SP ONE THIRTY SEVEN BY MISTER
DAHLE MISTER PAN MADE IT IN HERE
WE GO.
DOCTOR PAN WILL GO RIGHT TO YOUR
SB THREE FORTY THREE WHICH IS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION -- ON
HEALTH CARE DATA DISCLOSURE AND
THANK YOU FOR WAIVING
PRESENTATION ON THIS BEFORE FOUR
ZERO SO GOING TO THREE FORTY
THREE YES.
THANK YOU -- CHAIR MEMBERS -- SP
FOUR THREE FORTY THREE REMOVES
PROVISIONS IN THE LAW THAT
ALLOWS KAISER PERMANENTE A TO
REPORT LESS INFORMATION TO
REGULATORS THAN OTHER HEALTH
PLANS AND HOSPITALS.
TRANSPARENCY LAWS LIKE RATE
REVIEW IN HOSPITAL FINANCIAL
DISCLOSURES WERE CREATED TO HELP
PURCHASERS AND REGULATORS SMOSH
ACOSTA DRIVE HEALTH INSURANCE
PREMIUM RATES.
WITH KAISER REPRESENTING ONE IN
TEN CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS MORE
AND 40% OF INSURED CALIFORNIANS
WITH COMMERCIAL COVERAGE.
THIS INFORMATION GAP MEANS THAT
STATE REGULATORS AND THE PUBLIC
COLLECT DATA ON A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF THE HEALTHCARE MARKET.
AS HEALTHCARE COSTS CONTINUE TO
RISE POLICYMAKERS PURCHASERS AND
CONSUMERS HE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THE SAME INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
IS DRIVING COST INCREASES ACROSS
ALL HEALTH PLANS INCLUDING
KAISER'S THEY HAVE WITH EVERY
OTHER HOSPITAL HEALTH PLAN
ESPECIALLY ASKED WHEN I VOTE OF
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
BUT THIS IS PLACE GOOD MORNING
TERRY MEMBERS MICHELLE CAPITA
WITH THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION AND BECAUSE
THIS BILL WOULD BRING KAISER
INTO COMPLIANCE WITH EXISTING
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT
APPLY TO ALL OTHER HOSPITALS AND
HEALTH PLANS IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF A
MEANINGFUL POLICY IMPACT A VERY
MINIMAL STATE COSTS BOTH ASHTON
AND DEMI TO SEE ARE FEW
SUPPORTED.
AND DAMAGE THE ALREADY GETS AN
ANNUAL RATE FILING FROM.
KAISER RELATED TO IN THEIR
INSURANCE A LARGE GROUP --
INSURANCE RATES -- FOR US FOR
THE STATE ALREADY GETS HEALTH
FACILITY DATA FROM KAISER AND BY
FACILITY ON UTILIZATION AND THIS
WOULD SIMPLY ADD THE FINANCIAL
DATA TO THOSE.
ELEMENTS -- AS THE ALL OTHER
HOSPITALS PROVIDE -- WE FURTHER
BELIEVE THAT KAISER WILL BE ABLE
TO COMPLY WITH THESE --
PROVISIONS WITH MINIMAL
ADDITIONAL COST TO THE SYSTEM.
AFTER THE ACA A AND THE
COMPLIANCE -- PROVISIONS IN
FEDERAL LAW OUR OWN WORKERS WHO
PROCESS CLAIMS WITHIN KAISER SEE
THAT THERE'S BEEN AN INTERNAL
SEA CHANGE IN TERMS OF THE
VOLUME AND THE DETAIL OF DATA
THAT KAISER COLLECTS.
ABOUT EACH OF THE VISITS --
KAISER NOW CREATES WHAT ARE
CALLED ENCOUNTER AND CLAIMS DATA
FOR EVERYONE AND THIS WOULD MAKE
POSSIBLE NOT ONLY COMPLIANCE
WITH EXISTING LAWS REQUIRED
UNDER THIS BILL.
BUT ALSO -- DEVELOPMENT OF IT
HAS ALSO FACILITATED KAISER'S
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW HIGH
DEDUCTIBLE HEALTH PLAN OFFERINGS
SO -- WITH THIS MEANS IS THAT
UNLESS KAISER WAS TRACKING THE
STATE OF FIVE FACILITY BY
PROCEDURE INTERNALLY THEY
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
REALLY EXPAND THAT LINE OF
BUSINESS -- IT IS FOR ALL THOSE
REASONS THAT WE BELIEVE THAT
KAISER CAN COMPLY AT MINIMAL
COST TO BOOK HEISER AND TO THE
STATE.
AND OVER TIME AS KAISER IS
COMPELLED TO PROVIDE MORE
DETAILED INFORMATION ON COST
DRIVERS WE BELIEVE THAT THERE IS
POTENTIAL TO DRIVE DOWN
HEALTHCARE PREMIUMS IN COSTS FOR
ALL -- INCLUDING THE PUBLIC
PURCHASERS MCKAY CONSUMERS WHO
USE KISER FOR THOSE REASONS WE
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OTHER WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS YES MEAN CODE FOR HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA THE STATE WIDE
HEALTH CARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
COALITION HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
THREE FORTY THREE MEMBERS HEALTH
ACCESS WAS THE SPONSOR OF THE
ORIGINAL RATE REVIEW LEGISLATION
WHICH SB THREE FORTY THREE A
MAN'S.
THE RATE REVIEW LAW REQUIRES
HEALTH PLANS TO SAY HOW MUCH
THEY SPENT ON TEN CATEGORIES
PHYSICIAN SERVICES INPATIENT
HOSPITAL CARE OUTPATIENT
EMERGENCY CARE LAB.
AND IMAGING IN OUR VIEW BECAUSE
OUR HAS IGNORED THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THIS LAW AND THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION LET THEM GET AWAY
WITH IT.
MEMBERS HOW DOES KAISER KNOW HOW
MUCH POSITION SERVICES COST
SEPARATED OUT FROM HOSPITAL
SERVICES DO THEY HAVE A BUDGET
FOR THE COMPANY THAT SEPARATES
LAB SERVICES FROM X. RAYS AND
CAT SCANS AND MRI AND OTHER
IMAGING COSTS.
HOW ARE THEY PROVIDING CARE TO
ALMOST NINE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
IF THEY DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH THEY
SPEND ON DOCTORS COMPARED TO
HOSPITALS?
IN THE RATE FILINGS KAISER SAYS
THEY CANNOT PUBLICLY EXPLAIN
WHAT THEY SPEND ON DOCTORS
HOSPITALS LABORATORIES AND
IMAGING.
AND THEY POINT TO THE SENTENCE
THAT SB THREE FORTY THREE DELETE
AS THE REASON THE LAW DOES NOT
REQUIRE THEM.
TO THAT IS NOT WHAT THE SENTENCE
SAYS IT IS NOT WHAT IT MEANT THE
FAILURE OF THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION TO ENFORCE THE
LAW AS WRITTEN IS NO EXCUSE.
KAISER IS A MAJOR PART OF OUR
HEALTH SYSTEM YET THEY ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO THE SAME REVIEW AS
OTHER HEALTH PLANS THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE
CANNOT DETERMINE WHETHER
KAISER'S RATES ARE REASONABLE OR
JUSTIFIED.
BECAUSE KAISER REFUSES TO
PRODUCE THE INFORMATION THE LAW
REQUIRES THERE'S NO FISCAL
IMPACT TO DAMAGE THE BECAUSE
THEY ALREADY HAVE THE STAFF TO
UNDERTAKE THIS REVIEW AND SB
THREE FORTY THREE WILL MAKE THEM
COMPLY WITH CURRENT LAW.
THERE'S MINIMAL COST TO OFSHE
PAD AND ALL COSTS OR FEES
SUPPORTED SPECIAL FUND FOR THESE
REASONS HEALTH ACCESS PORTS SB
THREE FORTY THREE AND REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT
PLEASE KEEP IT TO A ME.
TOO OUR JEFFREY TAYLOR KAISER
EMPLOYEE AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
LIZ GRIGSBY A KAISER EMPLOYEE
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THE BRING A HOUSE.
KAISER I'M SUPPORTERS BILL.
LAURIE PIMENTEL KAISER EMPLOYEE
ME.
TOO CAMILLE BURRELL KAISER
EMPLOYEE ME.
TOO TARA SEEING GUYS EMPLOYEE.
DEPENDS [inaudible]
IN SUPPORT.
CHINESE WISDOM KAISER EMPLOYEE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
CAP CARRILLO SOUTH SACRAMENTO
SENIOR CITIZENS ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
STEVE YOU LAWYER AYE KAISER
CUSTOMER DEFINITELY IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT IS THERE OPPOSITION.
BY COME TO THE TABLE
[inaudible]
SOMEBODY.
THERE'S A SEAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN TREES
A STARK WITH KAISER PERMANENTE A
WE ARE -- WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON THIS
BILL AND FORTUNATELY -- WE THINK
IT'S UNNECESSARY -- AND AND
WASTEFUL AND AND RATHER PUNITIVE
SINCE AS YOU'VE HEARD IT ONLY
IMPACTS KAISER PERMANENTE A I
WILL LIMIT MY COMMENTS -- TO THE
FISCAL ON THE BILL BUT I DO WANT
TO CORRECT THE RECORD THE KAISER
PERMANENTE IS FULLY COMPLIANT
WITH CURRENT LAW.
FULLY GOES THROUGH THE RATE
REVIEW -- PROCESS OVER IT DAM H.
C. AND SENDS ALL REQUIRED
REPORTS TO OUR SPOT SO IT'S
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT --
I THINK THIS BILL UNFORTUNATELY --
DEMONSTRATES A REAL LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW KAISER
PERMANENTE IS DIFFERENT AND OUR
INTEGRATED MODEL AND HOW WE ARE
DIFFERENT FROM.
OTHER STANDALONE -- HEALTH PLANS-AND HOSPITALS AND AT A TIME WHEN
WE ARE ALL VERY FOCUSED ON
LOWERING HEALTHCARE COSTS AND
IMPROVING QUALITY AND ACCESS.
OF THIS BILL AT DOESN'T DO ANY
OF THAT SO WE HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT COME.
WITH RESPECT -- TO COST -- AT
THIS BILL WILL COST KAISER
PERMANENTE MEANT MONEY TO
IMPLEMENT AND IT WILL COST THE
STATE MONEY TO IMPLEMENT AND
ACTUALLY -- ANALYSIS POINTS OUT
THAT IT COULD ACTUALLY COST
OTHER HOSPITALS MONEY SINCE AS
THE SPONSORS POINTED OUT --
OFSHE BUT IS A IS A FEW
SUPPORTED -- AGENCIES SO WE
WOULD RATHER BE SPENDING THOSE
RESOURCES ON PATIENT CARE AND
OUR EMPLOYEES -- RATHER THAN
THIS RATHER WASTEFUL --
ADMINISTRATIVE EXERCISE --
HOWEVER SO HAVING SAID THAT WE
DO VALUE TRANSPARENCY WE
UNDERSTAND IT IS THAT AN
IMPORTANT TOOL -- IN OUR OVERALL
EFFORTS TO UNDERSTAND THAT
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM SO WE ARE --
WILLING TO CONTINUE TO TALK TO
THE AUTHOR ABOUT -- WAYS THAT
KAISER PERMANENTE CAN BE MORE
TRANSPARENT WE'VE HAD A COUPLE
OF CONVERSATIONS WITH HIM WE ARE.
HOPING TO HAVE A CONSTRUCTIVE
CONVERSATION WITH THE SPONSOR --
IN THE VERY NEAR FUTURE AND TO
HOPEFULLY HAVE SOME AMENDMENTS
TO THIS BILL BECAUSE THERE THERE
ARE THINGS THAT MAYBE WE CAN DO
TO PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION AND
AND BE MORE TRANSPARENT --WE
HOPE TO HAVE THOSE AMENDMENTS
DISCUSSED -- BUT FOR THE BILL IS
TAKEN UP ON THE SENATE FLOOR IN
NEW SENATOR PAN HAS COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH US ON THAT.
AND THERE WERE SEVERAL MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE
THAT ALSO INDICATED A DESIRE TO
A CD OFF THEIR WORK WITH US SO
WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT -- THAT CAN
HAPPEN VERY SOON THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
FINANCE.
NO FILE -- FILE.
DOCTOR PAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE
ANY QUESTIONS NO QUESTION OF
PAIN WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE IN A I
UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE.
COMMITTED TO HAVE CONVERSATION
WORK WITH KAISER AS THIS
PROGRESSES.
YES AND SO WE WANT TO CERTAINLY
WORK KAISER ULTIMATELY THIS IS
ABOUT -- TRANSPARENCY ENSURING
THAT THE REGULATORS AND THE
PUBLIC HAVE ACCESS TO THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED -- TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND AND ALSO TO
ENSURE THAT -- WE HAVE A COST
EFFECTIVE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND
ESPECIALLY AS PRIVATE.
THANK YOU THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO PASS IS THURMOND EMOTION.
I HAVE A MOTION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BATES NO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES JONES NO WE
CASKEY.
WE CASKEY AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT -- FORTY TWO WE
WILL GO BACK -- TO MR STERN IS
HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER DOCTOR PAN.
STERN PLEASE COME TELL US ABOUT.
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT IT IS A DO
CRASH WITH A SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SB SEVEN
FORTY EIGHT WOULD.
ALLOCATED TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
STIPEND TO FUND THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH POET LAUREATE WHICH IS WHY
I'M STANDING FOR YOUR TODAY
GIVEN THE SPECIFICATION IN THE
LEGISLATION THE CURRENT POET
LAUREATE GIVEN A FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLAR STATE AND WE FEEL LIKE
THE THE HOOPS AND THE THE
BURDENS -- ON USED TO ACTUALLY
PARTICIPATE MEANINGFULLY IN THIS
PROGRAM JUSTIFY THAT STATEMENT
AMOUNT -- WE'RE AS SAID DOPO
LORDS TO TYPICALLY TEND TO A
PERSONAL ASSETS OF THEIR OWN TO
USE HAVE WITH ME SOME INCREDIBLE
SPORT HERE TODAY WHEN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I'VE
[inaudible]
PLEASE.
MORNING CHAIRMAN PORTANTINO AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- WE WANT TO
THANK SENATOR STERN -- HERTZBERG
ALLEN FOR BRINGING THIS BILL AND
BEING SO SUPPORTIVE OF THE ARTS --
WE ALSO WANNA THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
PORTANTINO FOR PRESENTING INTO
HUNGER YOUR OWN POETRY.
AT THE CALIFORNIA POET LAUREATE
AND MOUNTED ME I DID.
SORRY ABOUT THAT -- BUT WE KNOW
THAT YOU ARE ALREADY AWARE THAT --
READING AND WRITING POETRY IS A
MEANS OF PASSING ON STORIES AND
CREATING AND DISCOVERING PEOPLE
AND PLACES AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS BILL -- WILL ENHANCE THAT
OPPORTUNITY POETRY FUELS
CHILDREN'S VOCABULARY AND THEIR
INVOLVEMENT IN THE LITERARY ARTS
AND THAT'S AN ART FORM IT'S
OFTEN LOST IN TODAY'S REALLY
BUSY WORLD.
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL WAS
INSPIRED TO BRING THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION BECAUSE OF OUR
PROGRAM POETRY OUT LOUD WHICH
MANY OF YOU HAVE PARTICIPATED IN.
AND WE REACH OVER FORTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN THIS NATIONAL
RECITATION CONTEST WHERE
STUDENTS ARE RECITING EVERYTHING
FROM PRE TWENTIETH CENTURY TO
CURRENT DAY POETRY.
AND THIS PROGRAM HAS REALLY
SHOWED HOW THIS INTEREST IN --
POETRY AT AS HAS GROWN
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE AND THERE
ARE SO MANY SO MANY.
YOUNG STUDENTS WHO ARE REALLY
INTERESTED AGES THIRTEEN THROUGH
NINETEEN AND WRITING THEIR OWN
POETRY.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT HONORING A
YOUTH POET AS CALIFORNIA'S YOUTH
POET LAUREATE WILL INSPIRE THESE
YOUNG ADULTS. TO HAVE A VOICE
AND TO REALLY ENSURE THAT POETRY
IS PASSED ON TO FUTURE
GENERATIONS.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL THAT DIVERSITY IS
OUR STRENGTH AND THAT'S REALLY.
THE REASON FOR HAVING THIS STATE
AND BECAUSE WE WANT THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL TO
PARTICIPATE ON WE DON'T WANT
STATUS OR GEOGRAPHY TO STAND IN
THE WAY.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE THE
APPOINTMENT OF A YOUTH POET
LAUREATE BY THE GOVERNOR WILL
GIVE YOU POSTED OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC SERVICE
DISAPPOINTMENT WILL GET THE
STATE OUT ALSO A VALUABLE WAY TO
IDENTIFY GOVERNMENT LEADERS.
AND WRITERS AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMMITTED TO SPECIFIC A
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
SO WE WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
YOUR OTHER SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
ANY OPPOSITION FINANCE FINANCES
NEUTRONS MEASURE AND CONCUR WITH
THE COMMITTEES ANALYSIS.
WONDERFUL ANY QUESTIONS.
MISSION MR STERN AYE IT'S GREAT
TO SEE YOU LOOKING OUT FOR THE
BEST MINDS OF YOUR GENERATION.
AND THE NEXT AND THE NEXT WE
THINK THEY DESERVE A VOICE AND
NOT JUST THOSE WHO CAN AFFORD TO
COME TO SACRAMENTO SO REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
TODAY AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
HAVE A THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL YOU
WERE SUPPOSED TO GET MY HOW
REFERENCE THERE.
HE GAVE ME HE WENT AGAINST BURKE
ON I WENT TO GAINES FOR IDEA
EVEN REDUCES ME THERE I'M DEEP
SEA HUSTLE SO I'M YEAH WE'RE
DIFFERENT.
AND NOW THAT WAS TO CHANGE ON
DIFFERENT AND WILL IN ANY WAY --
WITH THAT WILL TAKE A VOTE.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
I'D BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CAL SKI.
WE CAL SKI I THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WE WILL KEEP MOVING ON 
THE VOTE WAS.
SIX ZERO AND STERN YOU GUYS
ACOSTA.
TARGETED BOTH YEARS.
ALL RIGHT.
OPEN THE ROLE ON MISTER REQUIRES
FOUR FOUR NINE BECAUSE MISTER
HILLS HERE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR HELLO.
HELLO I KNOW I SO WE GOT THAT.
SIX TO ZERO ALL RIGHTS AND NOW
WE WILL GO BACK TO MISTER DODD
SO.
JUST EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT WAS
OUR LAST TO PASS.
EVERYTHING ELSE IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AND EVERYONE HAS
WAIVED THEIR PRESENTATION SO
WE'LL TRY.
TO GET THROUGH THIS QUICKLY.
WE HAVE ONE TEMAS.
WILL BE DONE IN.
NINE ALL RIGHT MISTER DODDS SP
ONE THREE SEVEN ON FEDERAL
TRANSPORTATION FUNDS ANYBODY
HERE IN SUPPORT.
ANYBODY HERE IN OPPOSITION
FINANCE THE FILE.
NO FILE SEEING NO OBJECTIONS SB
ONE THREE SEVEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AS THREE TWO NINE OH
MISTER DODD NATURAL DISASTERS.
SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION FILE FILE NO FILE
WORK CREWS AND SEEING NO HANDS
SB TWO NINE OH WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION.
BACK TO MISTER STERN SB ONE
FORTY SPECIALIZED LICENSE PLATES --
YES SIR [inaudible]
GO AHEAD [inaudible] ONE FORTY
MY NAME'S STEVE MILLER --
RESIDENT CALIFORNIA -- LIKE THIS
TYPE OF FUNDING -- SAY -- CAL
BUNGA CATCH THE WAY PAYING.
TEN IN ADVANCE THIS THERE YOU GO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IN IN SUPPORT OF I CQ COVERED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A SEA CUCUMBERS.
WE LIKE THAT ALL RIGHT ANY
OPPOSITION THAT FINANCE THE FILE
NO FILE WITH NO OBJECTION SB.
ONE FORTY WILL GO TO SUSPENSE --
WITH THE FULL BLESSING OF
MOONDOGGY -- SB -- FIVE FORTY
TWO MISTER WORKERS COMPENSATION
SIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE FINANCE A FILE NO
FILE SB FIVE FOUR TWO WITHOUT
OBJECTION GO TO SUSPENSE.
SB -- SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN BY MR
STERN ELECTIONS VOTING
REGISTRATION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION ACTION ME IS --
SUPPORT [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
FINANCE THE FILE.
NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO SB ONE
FORTY EIGHT BY MISTER GLAZER
EDUCATION THE CALIFORNIA PROMISE.
IS THERE A SUPPORT [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
NO FILE WE HAVE SOMEBODY HERE
YES YES.
GOOD MORNING MARIO GUERRERO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION -- WE REGRETTABLY I
HAVE TO ARE IN OPPOSITION TO SB --
ONE FORTY EIGHT WE THINK THAT
THE FUNDING THAT WOULD GO
TOWARDS -- THIS BILL WOULD BE
BETTER SPENT OFFERING MORE CLASS
SECTIONS -- TO HELP STUDENTS
MEET GRADUATION RATES INCREASING
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR RESOURCES
SUCH AS MENTAL HEALTH COST OF
HOUSING ETCETERA -- THIS THESE
THINGS WOULD HELPS A CSU
STUDENTS MORE EFFECTIVELY -- IN
TERMS OF IT OBTAINING THEIR
DEGREE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
ANY OPPOSITION FINANCE THE FILE
NO FILE -- WITHOUT OBJECTION SB.
ONE FORTY EIGHT WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE SB.
SIX FIVE ONE I MISTER GLAZER
DISCOVERY OF POST CONVICTION
[inaudible]
SUPPORT [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
NO FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX FIVE
ONE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE SB ONE
SIXTY FIVE BY MS ATKINS ON
MEDICAL INTERPRETATION SERVICES.
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE THE
FILE NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB ONE SIX FIVE WILL GO THE
SUSPENSE.
WILL MOVE ON TO MR NIELSEN HIS
WAY PRESENTATION ON HIS BILLS SB --
ONE SEVEN NINE EXCLUDED
EMPLOYEES ARBITRATION.
SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
YES ACTUALLY FINANCES OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE -- BECAUSE
ARBITRATION COSTS ARE TYPICALLY
SPLIT EQUALLY BETWEEN PARTIES AT
THIS BILL PLACES FULL
RESPONSIBILITY OF ALL COSTS FROM
THE NON PREVAILING PARTY.
WHICH MAY RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
ON BUDGET COSTS TO THE STATE.
ALL RIGHT WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SB ONE NINETY THREE NITROUS
OXIDE.
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE THE
FILE -- FILE WITHOUT.
OBJECTION SB ONE NINETY THREE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE HAS BE TWO
FIFTY NINE BY MISTER NIELSEN
CRIME STATISTICS.
SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION FINANCE THE FILE NO
FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWO FIVE
NINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AS
THREE TWO OH FIVE WE'RE GOING TO
MISTER HERTZBERG SPILLS SP.
TWO OH FIVE HERTZBERG BUSINESS
STORM WATER DISCHARGE.
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE THE
FILE NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SB TWO OH FIVE ABOUT A SUSPENSE
AS BE TWO THREE SEVEN MY MISTER
HERTZBERG -- STEM ESTABLISHMENT
OF A NEW POSITION -- SUPPORT
OPPOSITION.
THE FILE NO FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWO THREE SEVEN
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE.
SB TWO FIVE EIGHT BY MR HURST
HERTZBERG ON HOMELESS SHELTERS
SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
I HAVE A FILE NO APPROVED
POSITION -- BUT WOULD NOT THE
BILL APPROPRIATES FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR THE
PROPOSED GRANT PROGRAM.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ALSO
ESTIMATES FIVE HUNDRED FOURTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN
THE FIRST YEAR AND FORTY AND
SIXTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
GOING TO DESIGN IMPLEMENT AND
MONITOR THE GRANT PROGRAM.
SHE NO QUESTIONS SB TWO FIVE
EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SB TWO ELEVEN BY MISTER BELL
STATE HIGHWAY LEASES.
NO SUPPORT NO OPPOSITION FINANCE.
FIVE THAT OBJECTION SB TWO
ELEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE ALSO
BY MR BALANCE BEFORE EIGHTY FIVE
DRIVING PRIVILEGES SUSPENSIONS
[inaudible]
SPORT.
OPPOSITION THE FILE -- FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FOUR EIGHTY
FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MR WILK WAY PRESENTATION ON
THREE BILLS FIRST ONE IS SB.
THREE NINETEEN FOSTER YOUTH.
SUPPORT OPPOSITION THE FILE NO
FILE -- SB TWO NINETEEN WILL GO
THE SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB THREE THREE THREE MISTER
WELCOME HOMELESS.
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FILE THE FILE
NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION THREE
THREE THREE WITH OTHER SUSPENSE.
SB FIVE EIGHTY WILK ANIMAL ABUSE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION NO FILE NO
FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE
EIGHTY WITHOUT SUSPENSE.
MOVE ON TO MISS CHIANG CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE SB TWO THREE NINE IS
THEIR SUPPORT TWO THREE NINE WE
GOT A SUSPENSE.
SB THREE FOUR EIGHT STATE
AGENCIES IS THERE ARE.
OPPOSITION NO FILE NO FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THREE FORTY
EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SB FIVE SEVENTY THREE MS CHANG
ON HOMELESS EMERGENCY AID
PROGRAM SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
FINANCE WE DON'T HAVE AN
APPROVED POSITION BUT WE KNOW
THE BILL CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATES TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY. FOR THE A A
PROGRAM AND WHILE AGENCY HAS NOT
COMPLETED A FISCAL ANALYSIS OF
THIS BILL WE KNOW THAT THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT
APPROPRIATED FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THIS PROGRAM
REQUIRING TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND THREE POSITIONS POSITIONS
ANNUALLY FOR THE PROGRAM.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT BILL WILL
GO TO SUSPEND SAYS FEES FIVE
SEVEN THREE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE.
MISTER BRADFORD HAS GRACIOUSLY
WAY PRESENTATION ON HIS TWO
BILLS THANK YOU MISTER BRAD.
SB TWO FIVE FIVE BRADFORD ENERGY
STORAGE SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
COME ON UP.
I SUPPORT THE BILL BUT THE MORE
TECHNICAL ON WHAT IT MEANS TO
YOU -- EXPORT -- THE SAME
ELECTRICITY.
THAT IS COMES OUT OF THE STORAGE
THE WHOLE IDEA OF STORAGE NEEDS
TO BE -- BETTER THOUGHT OUT AND
MOTTLED NOT TO ANALOG MODELING
BUT THE IMAGE COMMISSION DOES
BUT THROUGH DISCRETE EVENT
MODELING -- TO MAKE SURE IS THAT
WE PICKED THE RIGHT TYPE OF WE
DON'T GENERATE A BILL TO US
SYSTEMS THAT HAVE TO BE FIFTY
LIST LAST FIFTY YEARS.
WHAT -- THE H. TO IT SHOULD BE
MUCH.
MUCH BROADER AND PUMP STORAGE IS
NOT NECESSARILY THE SOLUTION
THANK [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- FINANCE NO FILE NO
FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWO
FIVE FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SB
TWO SIXTY NINE BY MISTER
BRADFORD.
WRONGFUL CONVICTION SUPPORT
OPPOSITION NO FILE NO FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION TO SIXTY NINE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MS -- TADO HAS THREE BILLS WHICH
IS WAY PRESENTATION FIRST ONE IS
SB TWO SIXTY ON HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE ENROLLMENT.
PROPOSITIONS SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE NOVA -- FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWO SIX OH WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE.
SB THREE THREE ONE ON SUICIDE
PREVENTION -- SUPPORT OPPOSITION
NO FIRE NO FILE SB THREE THREE
ONE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE.
SB FIVE THIRTEEN MY MISTER TANTO
ON CALIFORNIA DISASTER
ASSISTANCE ACT SUPPORT
OPPOSITION THE FILE NO FILE.
THAT OBJECTION SB FIVE THIRTEEN
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SB TWO
NINETY ONE BYE MISS LEYVA
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID.
SUPPORT OPPOSITION THE FILE NO
FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB.
TWO NINE ONE THE SUSPENSE DOCTOR
PAN SP FOUR FOUR ZERO ON
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT -- SUPPORT
OPPOSITION NO FILE NO FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FOUR FORTY
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AS BEFORE
TWENTY MY MISTER ARCHULETA.
AN ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE LICENSEES
SUPPORT OPPOSITION NO FILE FILE.
MISTER ARCHER LETTERS AS BEFORE
TWENTY WE'RE GONNA SUSPENSE --
IT WITHOUT OBJECTION AS BEFORE
THIRTY MISTER WHITE COW SKI.
ON RETIREMENT BENEFITS SUPPORT
OPPOSITION NO FILE.
THAT OBJECTION AS BEFORE THIRTY
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SB FOUR FOUR
THREE BY MS RUBIO ON
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
[inaudible]
SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION COME ON UP.
HELLO DAVE HAS BEEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING.
OUR MEMBERSHIP BASED
ORGANIZATION WORKING TO RAISE
THE BAR.
CALIFORNIA QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING.
WE WANT TO THINK CENTER RUBIO ON
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR AYE AYE
DEDICATION TO EDUCATING ALL
YOUNG CHILDREN.
WEBER -- WE WANT TO BRING TO
LIGHT THAT WE'RE NOT GETTING
WHAT WE PAID FOR WITH
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN --
IT'S EXTREMELY COSTLY -- THE
ESTIMATE IN SB FOUR FOUR THREE
IS NINE THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER YEAR PER PUPIL.
THIS IS 41% MORE PER PUPIL THAN
THE CURRENT STATE PRESCHOOL
SYSTEM WHICH IS SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS -- PER YEAR -- IT'S ALSO
NOT MEETING THE QUALITY
STANDARDS ACCORDING TO THE N. I.
E. R. THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE FOR
EARLY EDUCATION RESEARCH IT'S
ONLY MEETING TWO OF THE TEN
QUALITY STANDARDS.
WHERE'S THE STATE PRESCHOOL
SYSTEMS CROWN NEEDING TO SIX OF
THE TEN QUALITY STANDARDS.
WE RECOMMEND -- AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR NAY VOTE WHEN THIS
COMES TO VOTE THANK YOU.
OTHERS.
HI MY NAME IS JERRY SPRINGER AND
I AM A PRIVATE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER AND PRESIDENT OF SICKLE
CALIFORNIA'S QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL --
DUE TO THE FACT IT'S A VERY
COSTLY BILL ADDING ANOTHER YEAR
TO THE K. TWELVE SYSTEM -- WE
WOULD DO WITH NEW FACILITIES AND
PLAYGROUNDS AND ALL THE COSTS
THAT WOULD BE ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT WE WOULD.
RATHER SEE THE MONEY IS BEING
PUT INTO THE CURRENT EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION SYSTEM RATHER THAN
THE IMPACT WOULD BE ALSO
NEGATIVE AND IT WOULD IT I
IMPACT THE CLOSING OF LOTS OF
CENTERS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHICH
PARENTS RELY ON TO BE ABLE TO GO
TO WORK.
AND SO WE WOULD ASK YOUR NAY
VOTE ON THAT THANK YOU.
IF YOU COULD DO ME TOO THAT
WOULD BE GREAT.
FIND JAMIE SUMMER MONSOON THE
DIRECTOR OF A PRIVATE -- DAYCARE
ON EDUCATION CENTER I REPRESENT
SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
AM I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AND SENATOR
RUBIO FOR WANTING TO SUPPORTER
FOUR YEAR OLDS BUT I DO HAVE TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
DUE TO THE NEGATIVE FISCAL AND
ECONOMIC IMPACT IT COULD HAVE --
OUR CURRENT MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM
IN ADDITION TO YOUR STATE
PRESCHOOL.
AND IS THE MEETING THE NEEDS OF
THIS AND IT'S ALSO ECONOMICALLY
WORKING OUT YOU HAVE AN
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PLAN.
IN PRAGUE IN PLACE IN THE STATE
AND THAT DOES SUPPORT THESE
SYSTEMS IN YOUR MIX DELIVERY NOT
USING JUST A PRESCHOOL BUT ALL --
PRIVATE NON PROFIT FAITH BASED
X. CETERA AND ASSEMBLY WOMAN
REYES HAS A BILL THAT THAT IS
GOING AT IS TO EXPAND THAT
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT WHICH
ALREADY SUPPORTS A SYSTEM THAT
YOU HAVE THAT WORKS.
AND IS FISCALLY SOUND.
AND THE REASON THIS WE ALREADY
HAD TWO SPEAKERS SO CURED SHOULD
BE SHORT.
THANK YOU OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT PERSON.
MY NAME IS STEVEN PARKER AND I
AM A PRIVATE PRESCHOOL PROVIDER
ALSO. ONE OF THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS YOUR POST
[inaudible]
YOUR POST.
I'M OPPOSED THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT FINANCE NO FILE --
FILE -- NO QUESTIONS -- WITHOUT
OBJECTION AS BEFORE FOR THREE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO SB FIVE TWENTY
THREE BY MISTER MCGUIRE
ELECTIONS VOTE BY MAIL --
ANYBODY SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE THE FILE NO FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB.
FIVE TWO THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
SB SIX THREE SEVEN BY MISTER
MCGUIRE TAXES PREVENTION ANIMAL
CRUELTY.
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
THE FILE NO FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB.
SIX THREE SEVEN WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE SB FOUR FIVE SEVEN BY
MISTER HUESO.
BY -- METHANE SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION NO FILE NO FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION AS BEFORE FIVE
SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SB FIVE FIVE EIGHT BY MISTER
HUESO COMMISSION CALIFORNIA
MEXICAN AFFAIRS SPORT OPPOSITION.
NO FIVE OH FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FIVE FIVE EIGHT
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING TO MS GALGIANI SB.
FIVE THIRTY CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY HARASSMENT.
SUPPORT OPPOSITION THE FILE NO
FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE
THIRTY WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SB SIX EIGHTY FIVE I MISS
GALGIANI ORGAN AND TISSUE
DONATION.
SUPPORT OPPOSITION NINE THE FILE
NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX
EIGHTY FIVE WILL GO THE SUSPENSE.
SB FIVE FIVE FIVE BY MISS
MISTRAL JAILS IN JUVENILE
FACILITIES.
SHE'S COMING OVER.
MAKE IT FAST DANIEL CAN'T A
KAISER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
SING NINE FINANCING FILE FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE FIVE
FIVE ABOUT A SUSPENSE.
SB MISS BATES HAS GRACIOUSLY
WAVE PRESENTATION CHANGE WHEN
YOU CHANGE YOUR MIND TOO LATE.
SB FIVE EIGHT NINE BY MS BATES
ON ALCOHOL AND OTHER DRUGS --
RECOVERY ABUSE -- SUPPORT
OPPOSITION NO FILE NO FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE EIGHTY
NINE WE GOT A SUSPENSE SB SIX SO.
FOR HIS FACE MY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES SUPPORT OPPOSITION THE
FILE NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THAT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE DID I
MISS ANYTHING.
I THINK WE'RE GOOD AND
EVERYTHING'S CLOSE.
ALL RIGHT THAT ENDS TODAY'S
MEETING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'LL SEE YOU AGAIN NEXT TIME